in the new year to come invest in taking
care of your body
invest in nurturing and nourishing your
relationships your time is limited this
is the thing that scares me the most you
don't have the ability to respect your
time nobody else will rise and shine
it's in spresso time good morning
believe nation it's evan my one word is
believe and i believe in you i believe
you have an amazing gift inside you that
i want to see exploded onto the world so
let's start your day off right together
grab your coffee and sip on today's
message use your time well
over you go go pal das there are four
things that we can never recover in our
life a stone after it has been thrown
into the valley words after they have
been spoken an opportunity once it is
missed and time once it has gone
considering the average lifespan of a
human being today to be about 70 years
17 multiplied by 12 is 840 now that's
how many months we have in our life to
live in this world and if life is
represented by a jar and those 840
months by the marbles in the jar every
year 12 marbles are being thrown out of
the charm
last year 12 marbles have gone as well
gone forever never to come back again
look at how many marbles you now have in
the jar to make a difference
to leave a mark to stand apart
utilize your time well and your time
will treat you well leading you into an
overall sense of well-being in the new
year to come
invest in taking care of your body
invest in nurturing and nourishing your
relationships invest in finding and
discovering your purpose your passion
your calling in order to enhance your
professional growth invest in pursuing
and cultivating a meaningful deep
spiritual connect and for some reason if
you found yourself stuck in any of these
some of these or all of these areas in
the last year
the new year brings a fresh opportunity
to press the refresh button refresh the
page of your life and live well because
at the end of the day remember we are
all just stories
and make sure
is inspiring if you want to make your
dreams happen then you have to remind
yourself that your time is limited this
is the thing that scares me the most is
that putting something off till tomorrow
putting something off to the next day
thinking that you have all the time in
the world to make that thing you have in
your head happen is a fool's errand
that's when people fall down that's
where people mess up I was having a
coffee with somebody in my team from
China then salsa the other week and it's
a girl she's at this job that she hates
and she came to me it's like I'm trying
to I'm trying to reshape my life I want
to move this around I need to go after
my goal and she tried doing this five
years ago she had this idea she's had
this idea in her head for five years of
what she wanted to do and she's never
consistently taken action
she's always put it off right it's the
winter it's too cold I'll wait to the
summer then it's a summer and it's so
nice outside let's go enjoy the summer
and the winter again it's too cold and
that pattern just repeats itself over
and over and over and over again and so
reminding yourself that this is
important that your dream that you have
has to happen today today is important I
try to see the the world through the
lens of I want to create something every
single day that my grandkids will see I
want to make something today for you
guys I want to show my grandkids this
video and if you take that approach
every single day and not putting
something off until tomorrow then you'll
start taking massive action then then
the time that you have will rise in
importance and you'll create work that
you believe in and you won't end up like
the person in my salsa group who five
years later is still struggling is still
not taking any action on her dreams
because it's crazy how quickly time can
fly by it's crazy how much people delay
and that comes from fears that come from
insecurities it comes from a place where
you may not think you're good enough to
be able to do it but how long are you
willing to wait before you take action
on your dream I love the example with
the marbles that he gave every single
year there's 12 marbles that are
emptying from your bucket and at some
point you're gonna run out of marbles
there will be no time left I think one
of the best things you can do is go to a
retirement home and volunteer and some
of these people if you talk to them
you'll just hear a lot of regret
you'll see it in their face you're hear
it in their voice a lot of the things
that they wish they had done and for
them it's really difficult because time
has actually run out they can no longer
do a lot of the things that they want it
to do
but you go in there and realizing fast
forward in your life to age 80 90
looking back on your life to this moment
to say you know what I still have time
to actually make it happen and taking
that time to make sure that what you do
today is important so whether you look
at it through the lens of legacy which
is I want my grandkids to to be proud of
what I make today whether you look at
the world through future regret I might
regret not taking action while I still
have the ability and time and resources
right now to be able to do it whatever
it is that gets you fired up to help you
take action today do that every single
day because I guarantee you if you've
started your day with whatever it was
that makes you feel bold and confident
you start your day with that every
single day and you do that for the next
year
your life will be unrecognizable
compared to where it is right now stop
wasting time now I've got a special
bonus clip for you but before getting to
that I have a question of the day for
you I'm curious what is the thing that
is holding you back from taking
immediate action on your big goal what
is the excuse that you're telling
yourself or the reason that's inside
here that's preventing you from taking
action leave it down in the comments
below I'm really curious to see what you
have to say thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso and enjoy the bonus
expresso give me go
what's the best way to find time to make
films while in high school I don't know
I don't have any sympathy for you I've
got a full-time job two kids
baby wife house bills life reality and
if I can find time to make some videos
everyday then you can - I know what high
school was like I did it for like a very
short amount of time if it's something
you really want to do you will find the
time
are there any a specific productivity
pieces or anything that is like really
added to your life you know I'm one of
those guys who like toys around with
different productivity systems and
what's frustrating I know it's not like
one system is better than the others
just a matter sticky with it so one
thing that I found that helps me a lot
is just plenty now my week sitting down
Sundays are usually a good day for that
looking at the week ahead planning out
the big important things the things that
you know are non-negotiable
non-negotiable and scheduling those out
and then scheduling around everything
else around those big big box yes that's
one of the things that's helped me a lot
and then also everyday just reviewing
your calendar and your to-do list you
know at the end of the day see what you
got done and see what needs to be done
with the next that's helped out a lot
you don't have the ability to respect
your time nobody else will ya know it
doesn't mean this you know mean to say
you you got to be a jerk about it yeah
there is something respectful about
people who own their own time and if
somebody calls me and says or what young
or calls goes through my secretary to
say they want a meeting
nobody gets access to to time with me
unless they send an agenda in advance
and you know we assess it as being
mutually beneficial yeah otherwise you
know I'm not gonna be be able to focus
on what my mission is I'm gonna be
serving everybody else's now you see
many people avoid that because they have
a fear of rejection they don't like
saying no I don't want to hurt
somebody's feelings yeah this other main
problem like you know you just give it
them to someone that's not about them
that's about you yeah being driven by
the good opinion of others and a scared
of rejection because you think yeah it's
it's a personal song well if you own
yourself and you own your truth it's
very easy to say no to people it's like
now I've employed hundreds of people
over the years in different businesses
and sometimes you've got to let go of
people and I don't see that as ruining
their day I see that as giving them an
opportunity to be in a job that's better
suited to them now they may not see that
over time you love them or scarcity in
broad out there or the fact that they're
you know they don't have wages next week
yeah but you know I don't want them
being in a place where they don't fit
and if they don't have the courage to
recognize that and leave it then I'm the
guy that needs to help them and three
months down the line when they hopefully
get a better job
yeah or find themselves in a better
position and you know they look back at
the time when the transition point was
there they thanked me for having the
courage to make that decision for them
if they didn't so I don't need the good
opinion of others if I'm walking my
truth and I'm always coming from a place
of wanting to serve it's not an
ethnocentric so it's not an egocentric
position I'm not like trying to say well
screw you your times my times more
important than yours I'm saying well
right now this doesn't serve our outcome
it's got to be a level of mutual benefit
yeah being mutually beneficial and yeah
if you need some time and this is a
project you want my advice on then hey I
have an hourly rate that you can book
but if you're looking for free advice I
have a huge amount of information out
there on YouTube that I do so that
people that can't afford my time yeah
can have access to it to some benefit
but other than that I'm very sorry my
time on my mission isn't aligned with
where yours is right now raise your
standard Apple at the core its core
value is that we believe that people
with passion and not one drop of most
self-worth depends on Europe it's
supposed to mean I don't ever give up
I'd have to be dead or completely
incapacitated hey believe nation if you
want to see my all-time favorite top ten
most a success I have a very special
secret video for you these are the
individual clips that I have personally
learned the most from and applied to my
life and my business check the link in
description for details